what's it feel like to be here this is
my first dreaming and I've been on
YouTube for four years and I couldn't go
last year and I was so bummed about it
so to be honest with you it feels like a
rite of passage I feel so grateful it's
kind of one of the only nights where the
whole industry comes together and to
just see that and to be a part of it and
for them to want me to be a part of it
it's such an honor like my mind is just
blown like little um II never thought I
would be here hi yeah you're running a
friends I mean this year has been insane
for you it really has been arranged
somewhat of a crazy
that's a good question a crazy crazy
year of growth I I was just telling her
that literally ten years like I feel 10
years older in the last year like you
know what I mean it's just like in
January to now I feel like I've grown
for 10 years you know so it's it's
definitely been a year of growth and
learning and bettering myself I guess
see what something film or I what's the
word like grown up or is it you're still
what's the vibe of Tanna 2.0 I think
that's amazing that's very sweet of you
I think that for a while I just kind of
felt like a kid on YouTube you know
making videos being crazy documenting or
whatever I didn't really feel like I'd
been on the platform for that long and I
finally feel more mature more grown-up
you know what I mean like I've been
doing this for a while and I feel like I
can make more educated decisions and
step back and think about things versus
you know old impulsive crazy young me
not that I'm not so young and crazy but
I was real young you know it's just
definitely different I definitely feel
like I've grown a lot on this space what
was it like to collaborate with Shane on
that video I wouldn't even call it a
collaboration wholly um would you call i
I don't know him saving me like my dad
like he always hi
no no but I lost my train of thought
because I'm a big david dobrik fan right
I was like we we should totally not a
collaboration in my opinion he's my dad
and he saves me through everything he's
there for me through everything he
really I was telling him yesterday like
he is the father figure that I never had
in it it just it felt like that but on
the internet the elevated version of
that you know what I mean and to even be
a part of something I didn't think you
know sitting on that couch filming that
then he would have continued to do
Jeffrey and then frickin Jake Paul and
like all that stuff just to be even a
miniscule part of that journey feels
like the biggest honor in the world as
as a fan a daughter a friend everything
to him like it just it's insane let me
ask you what is the biggest lesson you
learned through that scandal whatever
I'm like I'm just kidding I think we
definitely live in a scandal culture
where everything's a scandal with with
Tanika and 100% it was a crazy crazy
learning experience about ego about you
know like myself that like things you
can't go into something narcissistically
and egotistically and last minute and
doing anything filled by anger just
isn't gonna end well and I think that it
also really taught me about the industry
and then if you have a gut feeling about
someone or people or whatever it may be
follow that and don't make rash
stupid decisions just because you want
to or because of ego or because of
whatever like to really it really made
me make my circle smaller as well and
really think about who I work with and
stick to who I know and what I know I
guess which is content and not
conventions also so would you ever give
it another go Tanika I am having so much
fun right with music and performing and
opportunities that festivals that are
well put together that right now I'm so
much more focused on all of that I'm not
I never want to say never I never know
it's crazy because I thought that after
Tanic on it would be so many people not
wanting to work with me and it was an
officer it was a lot a lot of like
festival companies I'm reaching out to
do some bye I just don't know if I'm
ready and obviously one of the bigger
lessons that I learn
that was not to dive into something if
I'm not ready so yeah I'm kind of
waiting if I'm I'm ready so last
question for you is I heard that Bella
Thorne has 19 cats is that for real oh
my goodness oh it is absolutely 100% for
a fact for real her house it's like the
most controlled zoo you'll ever like you
walk in and you think there's no cats
and then you just artsy one and then two
and then three and there's kids and
there's dogs but it's all taken care of
so well and so clean and you're just
like what the it never no it's
everything I love all of our pets I'm
gonna I'm gonna learn all their names
one day but today's not the day we'll
enjoy your first streamys I think we all
can agree this is the only time I'll
ever be holding a creator of the Year
award but um to be real here you guys I
wouldn't even be doing anything if it
wasn't for Shane and I'm so sure that so
many of you feel the exact same way so
here is who the most inspiring amazing
reinventing creator on this platform I
love you dad I love you Shane
congratulations so now that you
presented what's next now you get to
relax a little bit have some fun I
finally get to like have a drink and sit
down and relax all night have been very
good because I'm sure I was super
worried about messing up sorry messing
up on stage and I'm super happy it's
it's over but it was so so dope like I'm
just so happy it was so cool I wanted to
ask you about the drama between Jeffrey
star and man it was wrong mother for
once it didn't involve you though didn't
you lovely
I know honestly seeing a scandal that
doesn't involve me I'm just like next
time yeah that boy yes you follow that
though of course I mean I think we're
all following every drama we live in
such a drama scandal canceled you're
over culture and you know who's next
whatever all that book I mean of course
everyone's following everything but I
don't I don't really have a comment on
it I want peace for everyone in every
community and everyone to love each
other and old friends you know to make
things right and whatever and I love
Geoffrey he's always been so good to me
and man he's always been very sweet
me so ask you this then what advice do
you have for them to overcome this
because like having gone through the
tannic on scandal like you know some
things you know no if I know some things
I think I'm just a scandalous girl
no I'm kidding but I think they they're
gonna figure it all out on their own
they're both you know business people
and so incredible in their own regard
and everything will be you know is room
for everyone I wish I was in that beauty
community you know for everybody's what
obviously